Actually here I have the product with me clear dim so some cool things about this is it pulls out bad
estrogens we are exposed to those in our environment in our foods constantly and it's actually the
number one cause of hormone dysregulation so this product helps pull out the bad estrogens. What it
can also do is it's been clinically proven to help with energy cholesterol levels and also dopamine
support as well so it has other benefits to it. It also can help with fitness as well so it pulls out
the bad estrogens that can actually promote weight gain and then once those are reduced to
testosterone can kick in and go right into the muscle itself and promote growth and stimulate the
muscle better than it could if it was blocked with estrogen the bad end of course. Then the good
estrogen can go into the muscle cells and then it can prevent the muscle tissues from being broken
down so it's an overall great product systemically for men and women for hormone balance and also a
few of some fitness goals you want to achieve as well. You can order this at shop.conorsclinic.com
or right here on the page you can go right to our web store and just search clear dim and that's going
to bring you more information on this product as well. Thank you!